[Music]
now in fairness you have to understand
how difficult this is for the left
they're they're in a very tough spot you
know though of course they put
themselves in this spot they've decided
to go all in defending drag shows for
children given that this is an entirely
indefensible and abhorrent and utterly
shocking and degraded practice there
really aren't any good arguments
available to them they could therefore
abandon their child drag advocacy and
reclaim whatever sliver of dignity they
might have had left they could throw up
their hands and say okay you know what
we may have gone a little too far with
this actually it is super weird and
disgusting to have cross-dressing
fetishes
performing for preschoolers
so never mind let's just forget about
this whole thing
they could do that but they won't
they never backtrack they never
apologize and never admit that they're
wrong about anything their only option
is to go full speed ahead all the time
and that leaves them scrambling for ways
to justify the pedophilic combination of
drag queens and children
this week on social media they seem to
think that they've maybe stumbled upon a
talking point which might accomplish
this feat for them the problem is that
the argument they've settled on actually
undermines the premise that they seek to
defend
once again they've pulled the pin out of
the grenade and then they just dropped
it at their own feet
certainly not the first time that this
has happened so in recent days mrs
doubtfire
the 1993 robin williams comedy where he
pretends to be an old woman so that he
can nanny his children without his
estranged wife finding out and it's one
of those movies from the 90s that when
you describe it now it just sounds
really weird but that movie has been
trending on twitter and that is due to
tweets like this one from alleged
comedian whitney cummings
who wrote quote
these old weirdos worried about drag
queens and kids forgot that our favorite
movies as kids were tootsie mrs
doubtfire and the nutty professor
yes because the people who don't want
men to cross-dress in front of children
are weirdos we're the ones who are
weirdos
but this comparison to old comedies
involving men in drag has become popular
um mocking concerns about the drag queen
child combination max kennerly tweeted i
was 11 when i saw mrs doubtfire it had a
lasting negative impact on me
specifically i couldn't comprehend how
they didn't realize this was cake icing
not facial cream had the whole world
gone mad my young mind was damaged
emily murnane another woman who pretends
to be a comedian tweeted in a similar
vein
it's true i watched mrs doubtfire as a
child and grew up to be morally to pray
a morally depraved loser and i do not
see how this could be a coincidence
well she wasn't joking about being a
morally depraved loser at least a guy
named nate david grossman chimed in with
his own version of this hilarious joke
tweeting you think that's bad i was 13
when i saw will ferrell dress up as
janet reno on snl this led directly to
heroin
now there are many other examples of
this talking point but you get the idea
many of us grew up watching comedies
involving men in drag and uh we turned
out fine
relatively so what's wrong with children
at drag shows
that's that's like the argument
well the first and most obvious response
is that to my memory
there is no scene in mrs doubtfire where
robin williams strips down to a thong
and twerks on the ground while children
throw money at him
maybe i go back and watch it again but
i'm pretty sure that didn't happen
that's precisely what happens though at
drag shows
you don't have to be the most perceptive
person in the world to notice a
difference here
namely the difference is that the point
of one
is to be funny
well the point of the other is to be
sexual
there's a reason why these drag shows
are not at comedy clubs they're at gay
clubs
there's no neon sign in the background
that says chucklehut or laugh factory
instead the neon sign says as was the
case in one of these drag shows for kids
it's not going to lick itself
the drag events are sexually charged by
their nature that's the point of them
that's why they exist the audience at a
drag show does not sit there and point
and laugh the whole time they're not
there to mock the drag queen for how
ridiculous he looks
and the children at the drag show are
not meant to come away with the idea
that it's absurd or silly or stupid for
men to dress like women quite the
opposite
and that brings us to the second and
most crucial point and this is where the
grenade goes off and blows to pieces the
people who tried to throw it uh against
us the point is this
mrs doubtfire
could not exist today as a film it
couldn't be made
and that's not because conservatives
would object it's the left that would
have a connection fit over it why
because the comedy and mrs doubtfire and
films similar to it entirely raw
revolves around the fundamental
absurdity of males dressing like females
we're supposed to laugh about it and at
it
the cross-dressing man is essentially a
clown wearing a ridiculous outfit for
our amusement
indeed the comedy makes no sense there
is no comedy at all unless you recognize
the differences between men and women
and believe that somebody in one
category can never cross over to the
other
the laughs come from that basic
understanding
mrs doubtfire is funny because it's
absurd and it's absurd because a man is
wearing women's clothing and that's
absurd
but the left says that we have to take
cross-dressing men seriously
they say it's not comedy at all but a
deep expression of their inner being
what's more they say gender is fluid and
so there's nothing fundamentally absurd
about a biological male presenting
himself as a female
in modern america mrs dauphire would be
condemned as a transphobic homophobic
gender exclusionary
reinforcing the gender binary and all
that
or else if something like it was made
today it wouldn't be a comedy but a
drama
it would be the inspiring story of a man
who identifies as an elderly woman and
struggles for to be accepted you know by
society and his own family
like if the exact movie of mrs doubtfire
had never existed
and then was made in 2022 the left would
watch it and either they would want to
burn at the stake everybody involved or
they would think that it's inspirational
drama like they would not see it as a
comedy
unless i'm wrong
perhaps i should take these leftists at
their own word
they're saying that modern drag shows
and mrs doubtfire are the same that's
what they're saying
okay so
can i then point and laugh at drag
queens
can i say that they look ridiculous
can i teach my children that when they
see a man dressed like a woman it's
funny and silly and they should not take
it seriously they should laugh at it
now i have taught my children that
that's exactly what i've told them on
the few occasions when we've been out in
public and they have uh
uh unfortunately incidentally witnessed
something like this
i've told them that's silly that's
ridiculous that's all that is
and i'm going to tell my children that
whether i have permission from the left
or not but are they now endorsing that
approach
something tells me they're not not
intentionally anyway
they're just saying whatever they think
will be most effective in the moment
even if it contradicts everything else
they say in every other moment as usual
and for that reason they are today
canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts
you